are you the best player in the draft
class i feel like i am
second steal for the ant-man and the
flush
edwards launches
reverse it if you can please
we're talking about kd you said you
think he's the greatest
player ever or right now ever really
[Music]
what's up guys anthony edwards here uh
shungar for university of georgia die
hard atlanta guy
about to enter the nba draft and i'm
about to take it out with taylor rook
thank you for having me at uga i feel
like i'm back in college
so take me to a college campus walk me
through your daily routine
wake up in the morning probably call my
guy david get some uh breakfast
of course brush my teeth wash my face go
to the gym shoot and have practice then
come back and play fortnite the whole
night then go to sleep
are you good at fortnight yeah i'm
really good when you do decide to leave
your dorm
how crazy is it walking around campus
like are you always recognized
yeah majority of the time everybody
knows me but i try to walk around my
hood on so i don't get stopped that much
well you know it was such a big deal
when you decided to come to uga
because you are such a big recruit and
traditionally big recruits go to maybe
some of the blue blood schools
was there a moment where you really did
think about taking that route most
definitely
when i went on my official visit to
kentucky it was exciting i mean
who don't want to play in rupp arena so
i was like man
i think this where i should go but then
i went on that
unofficial to the texas game and i was
like you know what
forget kentucky i'm gonna come here my
sister had just had my nephew so i
wanted to
see him grow up a little bit the little
time i did spend in college so
i think that was the most important
thing
all righty you ready for me to beat you
in samuno playing against three other
people too
yeah but i really care about beating you
because you were talking trash up there
okay
so who we got here we have my sister and
uga
student ryan justin who is your trainer
mentor tell me what justin is to you
like a big brother
yeah actually and also about to be a
loser no i don't know
yeah if i lose he gotta win
put it like that
justin anthony ready for the nba
always ready what's it like training him
from when i started to now
it got a lot easier when he first
started you know he's one of those young
guys that
not used to the hard work until it
rubbed off on him but i can tell you
once it roll up dog funnel he'll call me
to get in the gym now yeah wait wait so
if if the
if the line is under the number is that
a nine
yeah okay cool it's a
that's the name all right okay even
though i just showed you my hand
i know everything you got going okay
so you talk a lot about hard work where
do you think that motivation to be a
hard worker
comes from my big brother uh when i was
in the ninth grade i didn't work that
hard everything i did on the court was
just
based off god-given talents and
abilities that he gave me and my brother
used to wake up early in the morning and
go shoot and go work out like on game
day
so i wanted to be like him so i was like
man i'm gonna start getting up and
working out
yeah it was hard because a lot of stuff
that i did with my trainer i couldn't
really do because i was never really
working out i was getting frustrated
because i couldn't
do this move or make this shot or you
know do something so i was like man i'm
gonna get in here every day
so it can be second nature to me when
did you realize
okay i'm different like i'm separated
i'm separated from the pack a little bit
i'm elite
probably the under armour all-american
camp
i think i was in like 10th grade
everybody else was older than me
and i was just killing like every game i
was killing i was like man i think i'm
i'm better than everybody in here
yeah yeah who was there any notable
names there that we would know
yeah javon corneli trayvon duvall
um nasri okay very nice
i watched an interview and you said that
an nba player
told you that you can tell a guy's ready
to go to the next level when they seem
like they're bored
like with what they're playing yeah do
you feel bored now at all
yes i know yes because i get doubled
like every game i get denied every game
so
it gets boring and it gets frustrating
because i can't do what i want to do
and give the fans what they want to see
because i'm getting double all the time
man
they're locked in on me but no because i
mean my teammates and
they always make it fun for me so i love
my teammates they like my brothers so
the person who goes number one what are
the expectations of the number one pick
i feel like you should just come in and
impact the game immediately like
whatever team you go to and show them
that you can win
and you can win yeah yeah what makes you
a winner my competitive nature
i always want to compete i want to go
against the best every time i step on
the floor
all right ryan's like that's a student
here like what are people saying in my
anthony
well like george is a huge football
school but now that you're here people
are like oh my gosh
are we finally becoming basketball like
oh my gosh
what do you think it would take for you
jay to be a basketball school we got to
win
so we got to get players so that's why i
came here so they'll see that i came so
they'll start coming and more players
will try to stay at home
yeah do you feel like more people are
going to basketball games definitely
yeah yes okay before i put this card
down
i know unum your weaknesses but what's
your weakness as a player
i think his weakness might be just
staying engaged
for 40 minutes it's not about what he
can't do it's about is he going to do it
all the time would you agree
yeah yeah what do you feel about your
shot selection sometimes bad
but being home guarded sometimes i got
to take bash yeah
you got to do what you got to do yeah
well right now you got to put down
a blue if you have it um
that's so clutch oh that's so clutch
so let's talk the draft are you the best
player in the draft class
i feel like i am yeah yeah what do you
think separates you i feel like me on
the defensive end like if i lock in
every time i'm on a defensive end
nobody's better than me in the drive
of course i feel like i can score the
ball the best pass
rebound all type of stuff but i feel
like defense is going to separate
everybody in the draft
so you feel like you deserve to be the
number one pick yeah okay
a lot of really good guys in your draft
class so let's talk about some of them
give me an evaluation of cole anthony
i never really played against him so
like i played with him he's really good
picking rhodes like he's real smart he
can pass he can shoot
he's a great player if you guys meet
yeah give me an evaluation of james
weisman
i love james seven feet shoot
run the floor like no other plays hard
don't really complain about the ball
if you want the ball he's gonna let you
know he want the ball a great person on
and off the court lamella ball
really good point guard at like six
seven or six eight i guess i mean
flashy point guard okay we are going to
walk through some of the teams that
could maybe draft you
okay you give me your thoughts on those
teams right
new york knicks i mean new york i play
for anywhere
i definitely can fit with the knicks
they're like they're in need of like a
shoe guard or point guard whatever
whatever whatever position they want to
put me at i'm ready to play it yeah yeah
okay cleveland cavaliers cleveland got a
dude i'm real cool with colin sexton
he's from atlanta yeah yeah i would love
to play with cleveland
uh golden state warriors uh who wouldn't
love to play with stephen curry
clay thompson and draymond green gonna
be great it could make me better at all
times so yeah i'd love to play with him
atlanta hawks that's my home so that'll
be like a dream come true
if i play for the hall i'm real cool
with trey young so yeah and cam ready so
like playing for the hall
would be crazy all right speaking of
winners i have
two surprises for you okay i had two
friends of mine
send in a video for you
pay off in the today he's in this
position for a reason
i hope you all have a good interview and
i hope some good things come from it
you're a big michael big fan right yeah
most definitely
like seeing that to me he's the greatest
quarterback to ever play i love michael
vick so seeing that
just like i said it drives me to keep
working hard yeah yeah and it's crazy
you know he like watches this stuff and
i told her when i was going to this
interview he's like oh i know anthony is
i'd love to send one
let me show you the second video yo
what's up man my god
first and foremost just wanna let you
know i'm a big fan of yours just
continue to keep getting better bro
you got the talent already you got the
potential but stay hungry
and everything else will take care of
yourself bruh don't let anybody else
stop you from
achieving whatever goal you want not
only on the corporate office
all right this guy's living for you
peace and love yeah that's my guy
victor yeah we almost text every day
yeah really
yeah especially when he was hurt yeah so
you guys have a pretty special
relationship pretty good relationship
yeah
all right so anthony up there when we
were talking about kd you said you think
he's the greatest
player yeah ever or right now ever
really cause he's seven feet and can do
everything a point guard can do
over jordan yeah over lebron yeah
wow that's a great thing that's a young
fella talking
he ain't see the goat he can say he
didn't see mj in person he didn't see
that
but he's sure he he is that is
conviction right there he's sure
he makes people they miserable when they
gotta guard him super teams obviously
have become a big thing in the nba
would you want to play for a super team
in your career no
you're not about the super teams no
that's the only thing i didn't like
about kevin durant when he did that
says what about super teams don't you
like i just feel like if you
so good you should be able to win
without three four other players on the
team
okay like superstars on the team
yellow now we talking
skip you though
don't worry she ain't got a yellow in
her hand so we good don't skip me no
more how about that and i can and
she won't have games all right i got you
now what type of basketball do you
envision
yourself playing like what kind of nba
player do you see yourself as
i feel like a shoe guard loving to score
the ball but also getting my teammates
involved like a
bradley bill or something like that yeah
so this
is totally a dream never going to happen
but i'm going to let you
pick what a dream team for you would be
you can pick your yes you're starting
five current nba player oh current
yes not old no
at the one sorry y'all but i gotta take
kyrie
okay got to at the two james don't shoot
too much i can't take james
i got to take clay klay thompson yeah
because he gonna defend too
at the three taking k.d
at the four taking lebron and for the
five
i would say anthony davis but i gotta
take greek free
oh okay why choose giannis over
a.d because when they both was with
their own team like ads with the
pelicans and youngest
still with the bucks kindly i feel like
jonas did a great job
carrying his team all right now we're
going to build a team you're on the team
and it's kind of like the younger
generation of guys
okay okay cool start five yep including
you
all right me at the one
luca at the two jayson tatum
my four man bam adebayo okay
well no zion i didn't bam out about it
what what kind of ball would y'all be
playing we're gonna be athletic i'm
gonna tell you that we're gonna be real
athletic i got three scorers outside to
paint me
luca and jason tatum like those two guys
are prolific scores if you ask me
zion you can't stop them in the paint
the only person they can stop and
probably is lebron
and bam by the bio i feel like he's the
best on ball defender big man there is
in the league
do you think about what kind of nba
player you want to be in terms of the
type of career you want to have
i could pick now i probably would say
wayne wade okay why do i
i just felt like he was great in the nba
life yeah with the heat
he did a lot of great things and i love
like when he hit buzzer beaters he gonna
stand on top of the little things
he's going to blow yeah and i know you
have a good relationship with d-ray yeah
so walk me through this how does this
happen like how do you become
good friends with these guys or you talk
to victor i assume because of cream yeah
you talked to d wade
how do you form these relationships and
who's another mentor that you have in
the nba
well actually i didn't meet d-wade from
coach crane
i made d-wave from his son he was at
pangos all-american camp
and me and his son happened to be
teammates and at the time his son didn't
know who i was but
at the camp i went like crazy so like
going between the legs
digging on people like she was scoring
all type of ways and
i guess his son friend who was like his
assistant down there
caught him and was like yo it's his kid
on zaire's team he's really good
like he's really really good then like
they say you know he followed me and we
were tasting
stuff like that yeah oh that's great
okay what about victor vic
started texting me when he found out
like i was going to play for coach crane
yeah we just gained a really good
relationship and what about trey young
trey a young guy so we we've been to
each other
and now it's just like you want me to
come play with him so
yeah yeah what's that like so trey like
man
atlanta's got to get you landon's got to
draft just like john marant yeah
real cool he want me to come play with
him really what's that friendship like
you and john
i would love to play with josh yeah he's
super super good
he loved to pass the ball mm-hmm so i
love to play with somebody right now
yeah
and he's a dunker which is always fun
yeah yeah
so basketball you know is always
evolving he had like fast break game
post game iso game now we're very
positionless
what type of game do you prefer i like
playing fast
because i feel like i play my best ball
scoring early in the shot caught like
eight seconds first eight seconds do you
think you're a positionless player yeah
i can be
i can play one or two nothing more
nothing nothing more than that though
yeah
okay green no no no no no
my bad but i gotta do this to you go
ahead do it do it go ahead do it
get it over with that yellow car we
would never
do that no don't let don't let them do
that now don't let that gotta get them
don't let them do that
what's your favorite movie matilda
matilda you have to explain my favorite
movies matilda
i feel like women are powerful so
matilda
i mean she was a very powerful little
girl at such a young age
and i just like to see things like that
so when i first seen her i was like yeah
this is the best movie of all time
the best of all time i love that answer
i know
that you've had some very strong women
in your life your mom your grandma i
want to give you a chance to just talk
about
the impact that they had on you like
working hard
i got it from both of them they always
work late night it was the best
people i ever had in my life that i ever
met yet what have you learned from
having to deal with loss at such a young
age don't let things right i don't
really let nothing bother me because
of what i've been through so like people
coming to me complaining about this
about that
i'm like dude there's always a way
so yeah i always try to tell people that
man there's always a way
god got something better for you you say
there's always a way when you were maybe
feeling like down with
probably basketball i don't know was
this season difficult for you
with not having a winning record and
experiencing losses on the court
losing is always bad but you just got to
look at it like i'm blessed to wake up
the next day and play the game so
we were always worried about the next
game no matter what happened this game
we worry about the next game after that
why did you select number five as your
jersey number
my mom passed on january 5th and my
grandma on july 5th so
my birthday is on the 5th my sister's
birthday on the 5th so
i mean it's a lot of five going on
around so yeah yeah
okay when you go to the nba you have to
wear number five i pray to god they let
me get it
yeah yeah you don't seem like you get
very rattled by anything
no not really okay then what rattles you
something
has to rattle you being in the dark
that's it if i can see what's going on
i'm not rattled at all
okay opponents take note you want to
beat anthony
turn on the electricity no i'm gonna get
up out of there you have a night light
no i ain't got none
what's his player comparison he doesn't
have a true player comparison he's like
a mixture between guys you got to take a
little bit from this guy and that guy
he's unique where he moves he moves like
a smaller
guard but he's a bigger guard and then
when you find a bigger guard they don't
move like him and they're not as
athletic
yeah or they move they're athletic and
they can't shoot so he's like a mixture
between a few different people
okay sure i know you know she ain't got
you yeah cause she just picked up a car
when it was yellow and didn't throw it
out
oh no ah that card over there i feel
like yellow
so that's all that matters you feel me
don't change the color oh
look she knew she had a blue card
y'all
okay well thank you for spending so much
time with me today and good luck in the
draft
thank you so much
hey guys it's taylor brooks thank you so
much for watching my show
take it there but now that means you
have to subscribe to the youtube channel
you don't want to miss all the fun stuff
or the next interview so hit that
subscribe button thanks so much
see you soon